there are parts of Dark Souls 2's law
that don't quite add up unknown
histories certain character motivations
origins of the curse and of beings like
the Giants these are unknown elements
and that's not really a bad thing just
like in Dark Souls 1 these unknown
elements will act as the gaps in the law
we feel for ourselves in this video
though I want to question that law my
best videos are based on interpretation
so before I do any interpreting I want
you to understand which parts of the law
currently don't have any concrete
answers I want you to know what topics
need answering when the DLC hits and I
want you to try and find answers for
yourselves let's make it a bit more fun
though sometimes I'll engage in rampant
speculation and when I do this you'll
see this little button light up for
example did you know that gavlan's wheel
and deal quote is in reference to how he
Wheels dark diver Grand Isle around to
get to different locations so that he
can pay for his crippling alcohol
addiction to Heineken you can find
shortcut first two topics in the
description we have four major topics
and the first one we're going to talk
about is the opening cut scene so in
this cutscene we have to answer four
questions who are we where are we who is
the woman and most importantly when are
we
the most obvious question and answer is
who we are we are a Wandering Undead it
seems as if we've lost our memory of our
past life based on the dialogue and the
fact that these two are melting away the
second question where are we in the
cutscene at the start I actually think
that it's irrelevant we're just a
Wanderer who comes upon this old woman
but it becomes relevant when we come
upon the ruins of drawing Lake and
considering these ruins I think what's
most important is when we are the old
lady tells us that one day we're going
to stand upon the decrepit gate of
dranglake Without Really knowing why
this puts our actions in Drang Lake in
the past so when we arrive at this
portal we are traveling to a kingdom
that existed a long time ago and that's
where the entire game takes place so
that's significant so the next question
who is this old lady to lay this
prophecy upon us well there is a fourth
fire keeper mentioned in the fire keeper
Hut a fire keeper who left the others a
fair time ago I believe this Cinema big
old lady is the fourth fire keeper and
that's for a few reasons for one she's
wearing the red fire keeper Garb but
what's really interesting is that we
have a lot of evidence that she's an
aged Emerald Herald firstly in the
credits we're told that there is a young
and an old version of shanelot secondly
she has very similar dialogue to the
herald at the dragonairie when she says
that we shall walk those grounds Without
Really knowing why and lastly The Herald
mentions that it was her own
manifestation that led us to Drang Lake
the emerald Herald is also called fire
keeper in game by navlan the guardian of
the far fire the fourth fire keeper
the connection between the herald and
the Aged woman has also been confirmed
by people who are working on the
official guide so now that we know that
the woman is an aged version of the
emerald Herald we have our first
question why is she laying this prophecy
upon us why is she sending us back
the old women in the Huts say you spoke
to that kind old dear didn't you you're
finished implying that they know what
the emerald Herald is trying to do the
dialogue also reminds us that they've
seen other Undead pass through here all
who've shared the same fate hollowing
they have this air of disdain for what
the emerald Herald or the fourth fire
keeper seems to be trying to do their
sister seems to be sending Undead back
to Drang Lake through this limbo called
things betwixt perhaps in some effort to
alter the past so what past needs to be
altered if you watched my video on the
ending you might know our character's
goal in this game is to link the fire
the young Emerald Herald's goal is to
get us to link the fire the emerald
Herald tiredly guides the undead who
come through majula Undead who appear to
have been sent from the future I've
always thought that the Emerald Herald's
dialogue sounded really tired and weary
and if she's had to guide hundreds and
hundreds of Undead along the same path
to their hollowed fate then I could
explain why in fact this whole thing is
actually somewhat reminiscent of how our
character in Dark Souls 1 is sent back
in order to stop the spread of the Abyss
with Manus think about it the entire
game of Dark Souls 2 is about the Cycles
things that happened in the first game
in lordran happen again in Drang Lake
the framework is the same but the
players change so just like in Dark
Souls 1 when we were sent back to ulacil
to stop Manus and his Abyss were being
sent back to drink Lake in order to stop
Nashandra spreading her own abyss and
that's my theory anyway speaking of
Cycles though a lot of you don't like
the idea of cycles and that's okay do
bear in mind though that these are
Concepts much more accepted in eastern
mythologies than in Western ones it
really drives through that hopelessness
of what we're doing but if we are to see
a Dark Souls 3 then I hope it deals with
our breaking of the cycle somehow
because if we just get another cycle in
Dark Souls 3 that would be pretty
disappointing
so there wasn't too much rampant
speculation on the discussion of this
opening I think a lot of this
speculation can be fairly valid if you
find any loopholes in my theories then
let me know let's move on to something
you can help me with though the Giants
we'll start with the facts what we know
long ago the queen came to King Vendrick
alone from a far away land she warned
him of a looming threat across the seas
the Giants it's not said whether they
actually were a threat or not but the
king crossed the ocean defeated the
Giants pillaged their land and brought
back a prize so two questions come up
with this topic who are the Giants and
what was stolen from them and we don't
have definite answers to these questions
it's an example of a really major
missing plot point in the game
ultimately I think this might be
revealed in some sort of DLC but there
are a few ideas floating around
currently about who the Giants are so
I'll clue you in on some of my favorite
ones and I'll let you make your own
decisions in terms of a timeline we know
that the Giants appeared after Nashandra
came to Vendrick she came from afar off
land and warned him of the Giants
calling them a looming threat from
across the seas my interpretation is
that she used this info information to
get closer to Vendrick giving him
apparently Vital Information and
conveniently placing her close to the
throne were they actually a threat
probably not Captain Drummond calls the
invasion of the Giants misguided
barbarism and I'm inclined to believe it
if I had to draw a parallel to Dark
Souls 1 I'd say it's similar to how Gwyn
engaged the ancient dragons
so who are these Giants honestly I'm
just inclined to believe that the Giants
are an entirely new entry to the souls
series since there isn't really much
evidence that they've existed in some
other form in Dark Souls 1. one one
Theory I do kind of like calls them a
Reincarnation of dragons the ancient
dragon drops a giant Soul after all and
while everyone assumes that the giant
Soul was a part of the Dragon due to
experimentation with aldia what if the
devs wanted us to come to the conclusion
that the dragon was a giant this is
further emphasized when you consider the
plaque on the back of the medulla
Obelisk it's cut content but it says
that the Giants cross the Seas perhaps
to return home so are they coming home
to Drang Lake since Strang lake is
touted as being lordran who's to say
that the dragons aren't coming back in
some other form the only other link I
have to them being the same being as
dragons is that Giants grow into trees
and these trees could be the arch trees
of the dragons in some sort of long
evolutionary cycle but this is a long
shot also in reference to the plaque it
could be talking about how the Giants
left during Lake not necessarily that
they came to drink Lake all it says is
that they returned home so since the
Obelisk is a warm Monument I guess it
kind of makes sense that they're
commemorating the fact that the Giants
left that they retreated you know
anyway other theories say that they're
the Lords from lordran that perhaps this
is the withered form they could take
once they lose their souls a few people
noticed that the giant Lord's outfit
looked a lot like gwyn's it doesn't
really explain why they grow into trees
though so I wouldn't say that they're
the same race and if dranglake is Lord
run why would the Giants be elsewhere so
as much as I'd love an explanation of
what the Giants are it doesn't look like
we have a solid Theory just yet moving
on Vendrick brought a prize back from
the Giants when he invaded and there's a
lot of speculation regarding what this
could have been whatever it was it has
to be related to vendrick's ability to
create Golems since Drummond directly
states that he brought back a prize and
then the Golems materialized so some say
it's the Lord vessel which is cracked in
the basement of the medulla Mansion the
Lord vessel holds souls and studying it
could have given Vendrick the ability to
place Souls into inanimate objects
another common reasoning is that this
would explain all the Lord Souls from
Dark Souls 1 being present in Dark Souls
2 though this is problematic reasoning
for a few reasons one it's already been
fairly established that Trang lake is a
Reincarnation of lordran so why would
the Lord vessel be overseas in the first
place and two we know that Vendrick had
already risen to power and defeated the
four old ones by the time he attacked
the Giants so it's unlikely that it's
the Lord vessel some say it's the Ashen
Mist Heart which allows you to delve
into the memories of the withered this
could explain how Vendrick and ALDI
appeared into the very essence of the
Soul though it doesn't really explain
how they developed the ability to create
Golems and some say it's the Throne of
want itself I don't like any of these
suggestions but I like this Theory the
most for a few reasons a the throne
seems built for a much taller being B
you need the Giant's kinship for the
doors to even open kinship means to be
blood related or to share
characteristics or Origins and C
Nashandra implies that she wants access
when she bitterly remarks that Vendrick
never sat the true Throne so it could
have been the motivation for her to
invade the Giants in the first place and
D the throne is surrounded by golems
that only react to the Giant's kinship I
don't think any of these opinions are
definitively true or false I think the
intention of the developers was that you
were never supposed to know quite what
Vendrick stole and this is what makes
nishandra's intentions so vague and it's
what makes the Giant's intentions so
alien and once we figure this out I feel
like many other aspects of the game will
fall into place
speaking of Nashandra though there's a
fair bit that doesn't quite add up with
her so Nashandra is well known to be a
fragment of Manus at this point she also
looks a lot like dusk who Manus both
steals and releases in Dark Souls 1 DLC
if we follow this reasoning while we're
on the topic of dusk we can assume that
a duskism Chandra and is more than just
a damsel in distress in the first game
her name is dusk after all which means
to grow dark or B the fragment of Manus
that develops into nishandra simply gets
an impression of dusk or C the fragment
infects Dusk and grows within her
they're all possible and they're all
interesting I really like to think that
there's more going on with the dusk
since her name seems to imply a little
bit more when we meet Nashandra she's
sitting on the simple throat alone no
one quite seems to know where Vendrick
is but her with veliga saying the queen
has taken him that must be what it looks
like to veliga the queen tells you to
visit Vendrick then when he's dead
proclaims that dranglake is no longer
she then tells you to seek the throne
and do what needs to be done so she's
guiding you in the right direction she's
guiding you to the throne aka the Kiln
in order to link the fire so why is she
doing this she says it's what must be
done so it's almost like she's given up
almost like she knows what's going to
happen and if the popular theory is
right there isn't much that she can do
before Vendrick died he locked half the
kingdom away behind seal Gates only he
could open and then he shut himself away
so deeply in the Crypt that Nashandra
couldn't easily follow
so we get to the end of the game and we
fight Nashandra she tells us how we've
proven ourselves to her and how we will
become one with the dark her intentions
are still vague the only conclusion that
I can come to is that she led us to the
throne knowing that we were the only one
who could get that far since she
couldn't she then plans to usurpus at
the last second and Ascend the throne
for herself the official guide says that
she's found you the new heir to the
throne so it seems like she's been
waiting for a really really long time
why then are we able to challenge
nishandra over and over again in the
throne room once we've lost shouldn't
she have already won I mean she's just
standing there in front of the throne
shouldn't she have the ability to ascend
it for herself and the only reasonable
explanation to this is a that it's a
gameplay oversight or B that she can't
take the Giant's kinship from you which
means that she clearly knows very little
about what the throne is even after
craving it so much her intentions are
truly baffling and I feel like there's
something missing here and I hope that
there is and then there's the ending cut
scene I've always been confused by the
Herald's dialogue here so there's this
cycle where the age of fire Fades to
Embers and then it's on the cusp of
becoming a Dark Age and an undead comes
along and links the fire starting the
cycle over again so why does the emerald
Herald say that we're the one to break
the shackles of Fate it sounds like
we're staying within the strict
guidelines of Fate doesn't it in the
ending cutscene she says once the fire
is linked Souls will flourish Anew and
all of this will play out again she then
goes on to say it is your choice to
embrace or announce this is she
referring to how we can link the flame
and choose an age of dark or is she
saying that it's our choice to link The
Flame or renounce the cycle completely
and then there's the nature of the
throne room itself The Herald says that
Nashandra covered the first flame and
the Great Soul she implies that these
things exist within the throne somehow
since Nashandra comes here knowing full
well that you'll take the throne and
Link the fire so where are these things
furthermore do you think linking the
fire takes place when you enter new game
plus is this what the herald means when
she says that Souls will flourish on you
I personally don't think she's referring
to New Game Plus but many people do
anyway that does it for major topics in
terms of minor stuff we also have to
discover what happened to aldia who were
the prince and princess of alkan and
then why is Ornstein here we still don't
know and what's the deal with the hired
Knights so if you have any idea on these
minor topics let me know in the thread
in the description and with this video I
really just wanted to drive discussion
to these areas I want to put up the gaps
in the law for public debate so that you
guys are aware of what's known and
what's not I've got a link in the
description to a place where we can
discuss all these questions and when all
three pieces of DLC are out we might
just have to revisit these topics and
see how far we've come until next time
guys